good morning John so Egypt had a
revolution this week and if you're an
American like me you probably like
didn't they just have a revolution
didn't they give somebody else a chance
if that's how you feel and please allow
me to correct your ignorance as I have
corrected my own I explain what's going
on with Egypt absolutely as quickly as I
can
there are four main groups here that are
holding a lot of power let's go one by
one first the old regime which began
when Kemal Abdel Nasser opened through
King Farouk who was sort of a puppet
king of British second the Muslim
Brotherhood a political and social and
religious institution that advocates
that all Arab states should be based on
Islamic law he also advocate getting
there
through hard work and politics and not
through violence
third the Egyptian military which is
super-weird fourth young disenfranchised
largely unemployed activists people who
want a revolutionary liberal Egypt now
I'm not saying that those are the only
four factions in Egypt there's a 10%
Christian minority there is a crazy
radical Islamist side and there are
secularists who are not disenfranchised
young people but those are the four main
players in a story now a little bit more
about the Muslim Brotherhood actually
was banned in Egypt after a rogue member
tried to assassinate Nasser in the 50s
it was forced underground where it
thrived extremely effectively many
members now are wealthy and in the
middle class and they were for a long
time in government just as independence
they hold powerful positions they fund
social programs like schools and
orphanages and mosques cuz the kind of
rich and powerful but at the same time a
lot of people don't understand them and
are kind of afraid of them and the old
regime did vilify them a lot a lot of
people like them lots of people don't
it's complicated I loves to the military
the armed forces in Egypt are very
different than how we imagined armed
forces if we live in the Western world
or really if you live anywhere military
in Egypt owns a great deal of the land
in Egypt it can sell that land
autonomously like for real estate
development or it can lease it for
resource extraction they have a bunch of
factories factories that are staffed by
conscripts by people who are drafted
into the army and are recently now free
labor for the army and those factories
don't just build military equipment they
build like gym equipment and
refrigerators and Windex
they have farms and ranches and they
sell the Egyptian people their chickens
and their bottled water the Egyptian
military does not need to make power
grabs because the Egyptian military
remains in control of like 40 percent of
the Egyptian economy and they are very
powerful they also according to their
rhetoric have a sacred bond between them
and the people of Egypt and they are in
some cases
apparently outside of what we would call
the law that's gonna be important so by
2010 the current President now we say
president but really he's a military
dictator is Hosny Mubarak he is terrible
he didn't start out terrible but he's
terrible now he's ordered that just
ahead of a kleptocracy that extracts
resources from a failing economy and
gives it to himself and his cronies he's
also jailed lots of members of the
Muslim Brotherhood's of the Muslim
Brotherhood hates him meanwhile his son
educated in Europe comes back with a
banking degree and wants to completely
overhaul the way that the military
controls the economy so Mubarak's regime
has now pissed off the Muslim
Brotherhood the disenfranchised young
people and the military you can see how
this is not going to go well meanwhile
the internet happened and the 30 years
of censorship that Mubarak has placed on
top of Egypt is coming to an end because
he cannot control it when the young
people of the Arab Spring take to the
streets calling for Mubarak to
resignation the Muslim Brotherhood
cautiously follows when Mubarak is like
hey military we've got a problem right
they're like not really the Mubarak
steps down so now we're up to 2011 we
have Islamists who want elections to
take place for a new Parliament
immediately because they already have an
infrastructure for campaigning with lots
of money and lots of power structure
more liberal factions who want to first
create a constitution before electing
Parliament so that they can have some
time to use the revolutionary the energy
to create a revolutionary new
constitution and you know build up their
campaigning apparatus and the military
who just wants stability because they
want to keep selling land to real estate
developers and kitchen appliances and
stuff the military because they want a
new government as soon as possible sides
with the Islamists which is not a normal
pairing that doesn't usually happen in
Egypt it's important to note that
America is also calling for elections as
soon as possible because we don't want
it to be just sitting there as a
military dictatorship with the military
now and control everything cuz that's
not how we do things were American but
support from everyone except for the
revolutionaries the elections go forward
and yes surprise surprise the Islamists
win a majority of the seats at the bar
land the revolutionaries are feeling
betrayed by their military who's
supposed to have a sacred bond with them
and by the American government who they
thought was going to be a great
supporter in all of this it made that
impossible revolution possible and
they're not being represented in the new
government that is being formed that's
annoying worse than this crime is way up
the police have kind of been disbanded
to use on
Street are calling for the election of a
new president as soon as possible in the
hopes that they can get somebody in
there who actually represents them the
election happens and it is super
annoying because we have two people in
first in second getting 25 and 24
percent of the vote up being the Muslim
Brotherhood candidate Mohamed Morsy and
a candidate who basically represents the
original regime of Mubarak that we just
overthrew rest of the vote more than 50%
is split between progressive or liberal
candidates they don't get to be in the
runoff election so now we have to pick
between the Muslim Brotherhood candidate
and the original regime fantastic Hamid
Morsi wins barely weirdly enough which
is okay at first because there is a
mandate of revolutionary fervor and
Marcy is supposed to take that into
account but then he doesn't he turns out
to be really terrible at his job now to
be fair this is an extremely difficult
job they're difficult to take into
account all of these different factions
but he's not even trying he's extremely
divisive lots of intelligent people are
telling Morsi to stop being such a tool
but he refuses he's undermining the
biggest opportunity the Muslim
Brotherhood has ever had and stop it off
last November he passed a decree
basically saying that the Constitution
didn't apply to things that he said so
great we've got ourselves another
dictator fantastic so this makes the
courts unhappy it makes the people
unhappy makes military unhappy but the
revolutionary youth of Egypt they are
not having it at all small group of
young people starts going door to door
asking people to sign a petition saying
that they will take to the streets on
June 30 millions of people sign in the
end as many as 22 million people that's
more people than voted for him in the
first place these different people now
are freaking out they think that this
may be how the Civil War starts right
and the military is freaking out too
because even if it isn't how the civil
war starts 22 billion people in the
streets is just a logistical nightmare
so now everybody is asking Morsi to make
some concessions instead he gets on a
stage and gives probably the worst three
hour-long speech of all time dismissive
its divisive its defensive its drivel
it's other D words too so yeah the
protesters say to heck with June 30th
and they just go ahead and take to the
streets right after the speech
apparently 10 million people on the
streets across Egypt are enough to enact
the sacred bond between the Egyptian
military and the Egyptian people the
latere goes in and they remove him
from office using force these may be the
weirdest coup of all time
a coup that it should be said is
supported by a lot of people the head of
Egypt's military does not install
himself because as we said previously
he's already got a lot of power he
doesn't need that instead he installs
the head of the Constitutional Court as
the interim president hopefully the
first step on a path that will lead to
some stability so that the Egyptian
military can keep selling refrigerators
and chickens and stuff I only bit of
analysis here is that revolutions tend
to be incremental steps forward for the
actual people of a country they can be
large ideological steps but change
happens slowly vultures have to change
subtly because they are composed of so
many different people and people cannot
all change their minds at the same time
you can hope though and really we can
only hope that these incremental changes
are for the stability of the country and
the overall happiness of the people and
that's something that despite all of the
news media's prophetic ramblings we are
never going to know until we know it
does a guy have to wait and see Sabrina
I'll see you on Tuesday